we have clear acid from explore st.
Louis and she's with mine the president
of explore st. Louis kitty rats live a
good friends going to show many of times
great to have you back and explore st.
Louis for those of you who don't know
what it is once you give us some insight
as to what you do we are a driving force
behind a five billion dollar Convention
and tourism industry in st. Louis so we
have the fun job we get to tell people
about why I feel this is a great tourism
destination and why they should come and
visit that's all it's like new
initiatives that you have going on now I
know things are always happening they
are always happening and st. Louis and
that's what makes my job so fun you know
in the last year we just open the
National Blues museum here in st. Louis
and an incredible story here the history
of our blues yeah history the Blues in
the in the in the country and in the
world is based here in st. Louis and
that stories told in a new museum that
opened less than a year ago what time
does it does it open because I've always
wanted some silly Chester well I don't
think it's open in the middle of the
night actually so haha you are going to
have to find some daylight or early
evening hours no chess powers we just
what I'd like to be up in the middle of
it yeah every sign of physics well just
maybe you can get us like onions we
might be able to get you a professional
pass or something you know just like
just like chess is part of the the
creative culture and the creative mind
so is the blues and music and and that
all ties into the history of our
community and at the blues museum you
can go and you can make your own riff
and you can read all about sadly Chuck
Berry who just passed away but probably
probably not not only instrumental in
the creation of rock and roll but also
foundation of the blues absolutely so
it's great i'm definitely going i'm
gonna right downtown it's close by check
the hours i get off some crazy gesture
but also they must be other things going
on as well that you guys are continuing
i know the playoffs are coming up
although i think i'm not sure if your
hockey team the Blues are quite in and
of the mix somewhere and I'm with
anything else going on with baseball is
starting soon baseball in fact tomorrow
night no not tomorrow night Sunday night
Sunday night is opening season opening
day and our perennial favorites and
great team the st. Louis Cardinals are
playing the world champion Chicago Cubs
on Sunday night sorry I don't get us
tickets to that too wanna be normal and
i use you as a dear friend of you have a
look is very excited about its opening
day it's always a big celebration in st.
louis but to put to play the Cubs this
year for opening day is really special
rivals as well yeah exactly tell us why
you are partnered with the chess club
itself the economic impact that having
these high-level chess tournaments here
at the club that has on the city well
the fact that this this pairing of
championships these two championships
have been held here for nine consecutive
years is a pretty incredible story
regardless of what field you'd be you'd
be talking about what sport you'd be
playing that to have them here nine
consecutive years in the same city has
had a huge impact and that that impact
is not just a one-time new infusion of
cash which we love the new infusion of
cash every time the championships come
but it you know I think more than that
it's a cumulative effect a year after
year after year of having the exposure
of st. Louis as the chest capital of the
United States actually heard somebody
say the other night the chest capital of
the world I think we ought to adopt that
moniker and start using that this place
have some hyperboles anything but I
really do believe that that is there's a
cumulative effect on that because not
only are people coming here for the
event itself but they have spent enough
time now here year after year to really
become a part of the city of st. Louis
and to understand all that it has to
offer and we see people move here move
here permanently and that development
has had a much larger economic impact
than just the championship alone would
have well you guys do
great work and your great friend always
coming year after year we hope you
continue to come year after year and
share all the great things that are
happening in this city thank you I would
love to do that kitty ratcliffe the
president of explore st. Louis always
something to do always something new to
do when you visit is great Midwestern
town